It's not uncommon
for us to teach the same course,
but maybe with a few slight modifications.
Rather than creating the same course
multiple times, we can actually reuse
our RStudio Cloud workspace
using one of two methods.
We can remove all of our learners
once the course is completed
and reuse the workspace.
Or we can copy the workspace
for a new cohort of learners.
To reuse our existing workspace
by removing learners
we can go to the members
tab located at the top of our workspace.
From here, we can navigate to a specific
member and click the delete icon here.
We can repeat this for any
and all members in our workspace.
However, if we'd like to remove
large numbers of learners, we'll need
to use the rscloud package.
It's also important to
note that only admins can remove learners.
This means that if you'd like any
of your co-instructors or teaching assistants
to help remove members
from the shared workspace,
they'll need to have their membership
roles switch to administrator.
Rather than remove learners,
we can copy our workspace.
Copying our workspace
allows us to take all of the existing
shared files to a new workspace
where we will be the only member.
Just note that any private files
in our workspace will not be copied over.